I have bigger lips on you that's proof
cuz your lips can even hold in your
[ __ ] saliva getting away yo they're
too big bro that was discussed the first
one didn't go it hit my lips whatever
you and you breathed all over the gut
tape the top one please oh no yo
Corollas gone dog tryouts we're gonna
test Al's
cookies on live on air I made them from
scratch
mm-hmm show you some more scratch Oh No
maybe we can use no put the glasses
actually the aftertaste bad son what's
the what's the toughness of it oh you
know that you don't want them or what I
minister I ate too much
[ __ ] yesterday would you do with your
birthday yes celebrating his birthday
that we didn't know about cuz your
horrible friend didn't tell us son like
what is a bird I agree I don't get men
let's just Paulo you're right oh yeah I
know what's a birthday even though I
mean I don't know friends celebrating
love and worried about each other yeah
but well I celebrate that every single
day with you so every day's your
birthday I don't know should be you know
I text him every time I wake up in the
morning I go a bro we're lucky for
another day love you man glad we in this
together
except he did not my birthday one day
you're supposed to you didn't do yeah
bro this is a celebration Akash is def
raw dog his mom celebration of it mark
that's not how pregnancy works I don't
know what they told you in Christian
school it is a one-year gestation period
bro oh it's a little bit longer I think
right okay now that is true nine months
ago this day your dad
[Laughter]
never have a stork yo-yo I never hear
about the stork no more yo man that's
true learn about the stork why is this
work how know what a stork is to be
honest there's a pelican why they call
it a story it's a different version it
was different about it you know they
[Laughter]
stored might be our to dabble way
talking to cause this is Billy Halleck